des bateaux comme abandonnés des
plaisanciers qui semble avoir tout leur
temps oui il y a clairement quelque
chose qui cloche sur le canal du centre
bas c'est trop calme
c'est surtout ça qu on a l'impression
que oui les les bateaux qui normalement
font halte humains jour là il ne me
reste plus longtemps que prévu quoi
car depuis bientôt dix jours ces
plaisanciers sont bloqués un arrêt forcé
entre chagny et fontaine impossible
désormais de circuler sur cette portion
du canal
nous étions dans la dernière écluse à
chagny lorsque la panne est survenue
nous sommes restés bloqués à peu près
une heure au fond de lécluse on a réussi
à nous faire sortir
una stationner et puis on attend on
appelait les vnf mais personne nous a pu
nous renseigner sur la date d'ouverture
de ses excuses aux vnf trois lettres
pour voies navigables de france
ce sont eux qui sont censé entretenir le
canal et réparer les pannes sauf que
voilà
celle ci a duré un peu trop longtemps
c'est un disjoncteur qui a grillé mais
ce disjoncteur ils en ont plus en stock
comme si une installation qui anciennes
aux normes
mais l'ancien c'est difficile de trouver
des pièces et dont il fait qu'on trouve
une solution autre pour réparer ce canal
certains n'hésitent pas ici à le
qualifier de vieillot de quoi poser la
question de sa réhabilitation
plus de deux siècles après son ouverture
sous différencie de choses c'est un
canal qui est ancien mais les
installations sont vérifiées
régulièrement et sont aux normes
donc il ya des ouvrages qui sont anciens
donc c'est normal qui dépanne mais là
c'est une panne qu'on pouvait pas
prévoir
vnf assure donc faire le nécessaire pour
ouvrir ses écluses à partir de ce week
end
mais attention la solution trouvée n'est
que provisoire à partir de la fin du
mois d'octobre
des travaux d'envergure devrait être
réalisée